Priya Singh: Today’s focus: notification digest emails.
Jordan Patel: Any blockers from last time?
Jordan Patel: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Priya Singh: Infra-wise, Specifically for notification digest emails.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on notification digest emails; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for notification digest emails.
Noah Williams: We’ll need QA test cases listed on notification digest emails.
Priya Singh: Any risks we’re missing? on notification digest emails.
Avery Kim: Action: write migration.
Noah Williams: I think we split notification digest emails into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on notification digest emails; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: I propose we split notification digest emails into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Risk: scope creep for notification digest emails.
Riley Chen: We’ll need QA test cases listed on notification digest emails.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on notification digest emails; start with a spike.
Noah Williams: Observability dashboards for errors on notification digest emails.
Samira López: Infra-wise, Tests should cover unhappy paths.
Riley Chen: I think we split notification digest emails into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: From design side, Security review is likely.
Riley Chen: Infra-wise, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Samira López: Edge cases around auth and retries on notification digest emails.
Riley Chen: Risk: scope creep for notification digest emails.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on notification digest emails; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: I think we split notification digest emails into two subtasks.
Samira López: Edge cases around auth and retries on notification digest emails.
Jordan Patel: Risk: data migration for notification digest emails.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on notification digest emails; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: From QA perspective, Specifically for notification digest emails.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on notification digest emails; start with a spike.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: I think we split notification digest emails into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: We need to timebox the spike on notification digest emails.
Jordan Patel: Action: create test plan.
Samira López: From QA perspective, Quick update on the scope.
Jordan Patel: Infra-wise, Design feedback is pending.
Noah Williams: From QA perspective, We might need a migration.
Priya Singh: Observability dashboards for errors on notification digest emails.
Priya Singh: Infra-wise, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Priya Singh: Okay, who can take ownership?
Riley Chen: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Jordan Patel: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.